now
can you explain who this man by the name
of
jimmy seville is
jimmy savile was uh okay
yeah long time um
celebrity big time celebrity very
popular
in britain and
he is also officially in britain
the most prolific
sex abuser in
british history he had hundreds of
victims
he did both child sex abuse and satanist
ritual abuse
his core beliefs were satanism
satanists often disguise themselves
under other religious groups or
atheism but they call believe their real
belief system
if they are satanists will be satanism
because satanism demands
100 commitment and they are only
adopting that
appearance as a disguise
as a concealment so jimmy several
pretended to be
roman catholic but his
all the rapes he he committed over
decades
uh in fact the last known alleged rape
that he committed was when he was 82
years old
and satanism
and sra of jimmy savol was exposed by
one courageous newspaper in the uk known
as the sunday
express and they
had survivors testimonies of having been
ritually abused as children by jimmy
savol
and then another
sra survivor of jimmy several saw that
first article
came forward and shared her testimony
and then made
the story for the second article
on jimmy several's satanism and sra
and then a third person well another
person who
had quietly documented jimmy savelle's
visit to his town
in northern england for years to attend
satanic rituals
produced his research to the sunday
express
and they did a third article on jimmy
several satanism
[Music]
uh based on that i have the links to all
the articles if people want to
to look at them they're on the internet
uh and is there a place where people can
go to
sort of look at all this stuff like do
you have a website where people can look
at yes
i have a website which has these
articles as well
i will email you my website
uh the name of the website is is kasra
coalition against satanist ritual abuse
i will email you that and my email
address as well for people who might
want to get in touch
because they need help uh with
with a sra case
and the important thing is he got away
with it
he was raping so many
children over decades and in some cases
adults hundreds more than
450 in total
and uh he was never arrested
he was never charged with the crimes he
did
the now how do you sorry how do you know
it's 450 how many people have come
forward
and spoken about this or have claimed to
be victims of jimmy
the numbers attributed to him based on
the
hundreds of victims who came forward
hundreds of victims came forward
yeah it's about 450.
wow hundreds of victims came from
unfortunately
but by the time they came forward he had
already died
but some had tried some said they had
tried when he was still alive
to tell others about the abuse they
suffered
uh one child had tried at least one
child that tried
and was disbelieved because the the
problem with the
with the attitude here at least probably
the same in america is
oh he's a well-known and respected
celebrity
he can't possibly have done such awful
things
perhaps today we're a bit more street
wise about celebrities that they do
do dark things sometimes when they think
they're not being watched
uh they're not that they're not uh
shiny white and clean as they may
present themselves
but uh probably back then a couple of
decades ago
when you try to expose a celebrity it
will be even much much harder
to do so and
so the child who tried to expose what
savile did to her was simply disbelieved
and
scolded for her troubles and this is
what
we we need to learn i mean we we can't
get several now obviously he's already
dead but
are we going to learn that just because
a person is a celebrity
should not make that person bulletproof
when it comes to
sex abuse allegations
are we willing to look more closely at
the celebrities
and not simply buy the personality
as authentic that they are trying to
present to us
uh are we going to listen to the victims
this is very key issue
do we actually listen
seriously to victims whether they're
children or adults
uh of sex abuse
i'm not saying hundred percent of them
100 of the time are going to be
accurate but i would say that most of
the time
they are accurate and we should
seriously
consider rather than simply dismiss off
hand
which which often happens uh their
allegations of sex abuse whether it's
sra
or child sex abuse we need to
take these issues seriously and
thoroughly investigate them
because they are serious in the uk at
least we have a
common problem of the police
not thoroughly investigating
sra allegations and
sometimes just going through the motions
of investigating
and then shutting it down and the common
excuse and it's just an excuse
is there's not enough evidence of course
there's not going to be enough evidence
if you don't bother to thoroughly
investigate
whatever evidence you have got now so it
just becomes a
self-fulfilling prophecy if they start
off the investigation with the attitude
of well there's not gonna be enough
evidence
and and then they're just going through
the motions
they're just putting on a show in that
sense
and that has allowed the sra to continue
with near impunity
you know as i say to people here
impunity is not something confined
only to certain latin american banana
republics
impunity is alive and well in the uk
when it comes to sra it has been going
on for years
and the police have repeatedly
not done their job properly to
thoroughly investigate
it and even with child sex abuse cases
which are not sra
the police have also failed there
especially in both csa and sra cases
especially
when certain vips are involved
of course one vip would have been jimmy
savol
the police are reluctant to pursue
investigations
was jimmy savile connected to the royal
family
in the uk and
do you think the situation with
jeffrey epstein and gillane maxwell
is connected to all of this
i would say that uh in jimmy savile's
case he knew
prince charles which is quite public
uh he it does not mean
that there is strong evidence
to indicate that prince charles was
somehow involved in this
i've heard people alleging that the
royal family are somehow involved
in sra
[Music]
i remain open-minded but i at this
present time will not go so far as to
say they are involved
because i have yet to interview
a sra survivor who said
such and such royal family member
ritually abused me and i have yet to
meet anyone who can corroborate that
allegation
so i i leave it open for now
um i cannot say at this point because i
haven't come across the witnesses
myself so far that
that they are involved in sra
uh the epstein case
one thing i would say is that
it's being presented as child sex abuse
pedophilia rather than as a
satanic abuse case so
i suspect there are probably sra
elements
and satanist elements in the epstein
case
i wouldn't be surprised at all if
epstein was a satanist
who did sra but
the publicity surrounding it so far has
not
really revealed and it's not surprising
because especially when it comes to
well-known people there's often
a kind of cover-up by the media
to hide the satanic sra aspects of the
case
that's what happened with savile by the
way only one uk newspaper
had the guts to expose the satanism and
sra
in the several case other newspapers
wrote
loads of articles about seville without
even mentioning satanism or sra once
so it was all this coverage which left
out some of the key issues there because
if you want to know
and these newspapers are all asking do
you if you want to know
how he managed to get away with it
for so many years i would say
well first you got to expose the
satanism and sra because
a lot of the cases in the uk i would say
the majority of
covered up child sex abuse cases in the
uk are sra
they are more likely to be covered up
than the
so-called ordinary child sex abuse cases
uh because there are connections between
the satanists and influential people
some of the satanists are themselves
influential people
there's also the links with freemasonry
so
uh i'm waiting to see and i hope it will
happen soon that the epstein case
if there are satanic elements in it
that that will be publicly exposed by
the media
uh one interesting thing about epstein
that could be a clue
to satanist involvement is that he had
an unusual
unusually strong interest in eugenics
uh eugenics and he even spoke at
conferences on eugenics can you explain
what eugenics is
eugenics is basically about
to put it bluntly getting rid of the
less
the less supposedly intelligent people
and the less successful people and those
from the lower
rungs of society uh getting rid of them
getting rid of those who are considered
a burden to society
uh so as to improve the
so-called gene pool and
to have a supposedly better quality of
human being being reproduced
and it kind of falls in
pretty pretty much with satanist
attitudes
it's very elitist and
has a kind of ruthless attitude of well
we don't want
these riffraff to be reproducing
so we'll find ways to stop them
reproducing
or to kill off their their offspring
or to abort their offspring one example
would be
there's quite a push by pro-abortionists
to
abort babies with down syndrome
and to stop any down syndrome child from
[Music]
being born and that's their solution
inverted commerce to the
problem of down syndrome get rid of all
of them so there's no more i bought them
all in the womb no more down syndrome
problem solved because we kill all of
them up
i